writing is powerful hi there steve
kaufman here
and today i want to talk about the sixth
of my the sixth number six of my uh
personal priority in language learning
goals and that is
writing remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe click on the
bell for notifications and if you follow
me on a podcast service which i
recommend
uh if you're
working on improving your language
skills your english language skills uh
please leave a review there
all right
so
remember that these goals are this is my
own priority of goals so this is not
necessarily what i would recommend as a
priority of goals for everyone in every
situation but it's my situation all
right for me writing comes at the end of
my or near the end of my
language learning goals even though all
of these goals are somewhat
interchangeable
but remember that i say my first goal is
to increase my vocabulary acquire words
largely passive vocabulary that enables
me then to start reading
and once i read then i can begin to
understand what i'm listening to so then
listening it comes after reading as
number three
and then once i've been doing a lot of
listening i start to feel i can start
saying something to start speaking
and when i start speaking then i realize
that i need to improve the accuracy of
my use of the language in other words to
focus in a little bit on grammar so
that's number five
now
therefore then comes writing now writing
i personally don't do a lot of writing
now in the languages that i'm learning
but some of the languages that i speak
quite well like french and chinese
when i learned those languages i did a
lot of writing
and there's no question that writing is
a powerful way to improve our language
skills
and it has a number it's kind of it's a
form of output just like speaking is a
form of output but it has a big
advantage over speaking and that is that
when you write
you have the chance to look things up
uh check the conjugation table or the
declension tables or look up a word
or maybe look at some of the phrases
that you've saved on link and try to use
them in other words you aren't forced as
in speaking to just use whatever comes
to mind you can actually do a little
more research you can actually improve
the accuracy of your output
your ability to express yourself
in the more sort of relaxed atmosphere
of writing so i it's definitely
something that i recommend
now one of the difficulties is so when i
was
learning chinese i was assigned writing
assignments i had to write
in french i was first of all i had
french at school and then in france i
had essays to write i had things to
write
so you have to find meaningful things to
write about
um
because you don't want to just write
stuff so so what can you do well you can
keep a diary if you're that way inclined
uh you can
you know there's so many opportunities
to through email or through
different
chat rooms or
maintaining a blog i mean the sky's the
limit communicating with people or just
keeping track of your own activities or
what you're doing in the target language
there are many opportunities probably
more
than
when i was learning 50 years ago
of having meaningful occasions where you
can write and writing is powerful you
will
improve your grasp of vocabulary you
will improve your grasp of grammar
by writing now
obviously there are difficulties if
you're learning a language with a
different writing system
um
which has been the case for me and and
certainly in greek and ukrainian in
russian in persian and arabic but there
again
because we now have the ability to type
it's it's a lot easier to type the
language
to write online and as you're writing
online to look up words and look up
grammar points
it's more difficult to write by hand
writing by hand is something that i have
not done a lot of
but i i think there's some evidence that
when you write by hand you improve
your ability to retain what you're
learning
again because i am a
call a dilettante learner i'm not under
any obligation to learn anything so i do
whatever is easiest and writing online
is easier i can go even further
uh i can dictate on my ipad
and so i get away from the idea of
writing whatsoever but i still have some
of the advantages of writing because i
see what i dictated i can go in and
correct it or change some words or
somehow
um you know still have that
advantage of writing and that is that
you have more time to express yourself
but i don't have to remember how to form
the letters
uh so these are different ways that you
can engage in writing as a means of
developing your output
ability the other thing is
when we write some people
maybe think that they have to write
in a more formal way than they speak and
perhaps in some situations you do
there's formal communications business
letters and so forth less and less the
case today
my approach to writing has always been
to write the way i speak so i tend to
you know
develop a somewhat neutral way of
speaking so i'm not too informal not too
much slang
and then my writing is just an extension
of my speaking so i write the way i
speak so if you have a neutral
fairly
not
formal but sort of standard way of
expressing yourself when you speak then
that kind of becomes the way you express
yourself in writing and i personally
find it's easier to do that to make your
writing and extension of your speaking
also when it comes to writing
people say well you know there's
business english and there's medical
english and there's this english or
other languages there's is sort of
special
english
here again
you're only going to be able to write as
well as you read
so if you need a special
academic english or french or whatever
the language may be or business english
or
medical english you have to consume a
lot of content
you know in that domain
if you want to write in a more literary
way then you have to consume a lot of
literature
the the best way
the best thing you can do to write
better is to read more
because that way sort of a correct
expression
somewhat more sophisticated expression
more
elegant more eloquent more accurate
expression will become second nature
because you've done so much listening
and reading of that kind of material of
course you can have your writing
corrected but my experience is that
corrections aren't as effective
as a means of improving in the language
as
more and more exposure so people who
want to improve their ability to write
still have to focus in on
the previous goals in other words
acquiring a large vocabulary
do a lot of reading do a lot of
listening
even your speaking activity is going to
improve your ability to write
and of course to the extent that you
spend time on grammar it's also going to
improve your ability to write so you
have to do all of these things
in order to become better at writing
don't rely on having your writing
corrected it's probably the least
important
activity in terms of improving your
ability to write so
there are my thoughts on writing my fif
sixth goal
i did a couple of videos on the subject
of writing a while back one is called
write more to improve improve your
language accuracy the other one is
called the importance of writing and
language learning you might want to have
a look at those to see some more
discussion of this subject
so thank you for listening bye for now